[Music]
as a movie based on an attraction at
disneyland jungle cruise is chock full
of easter eggs and other small nods to
the rides adventureland home
here are some you may have missed a
fictional character in the jungle cruise
adventureland universe dr albert falls
was introduced in the attraction as a
joke the namesake of the famous
schweitzer falls which he discovered
albert fall's characterization grew with
the expansion of the jungle crew's
backstory in 2015.
now albert's books and other items found
on his travels are featured on shelves
in the skipper canteen restaurant and
there's a bronze bust of the famed
fictional explorer in trader sam's at
the disneyland hotel
in the jungle cruise film dr albert
falls is an off-screen character whose
travel documents maps and an arrowhead
are sought after by dr lily houghton and
prince joaquim in their search for the
coveted healing tree
in the beginning of the movie lily
breaks into and snoops around in english
archaeological society's archives and
finds the arrow she's looking for inside
a crate labeled with dr
a falls albert falls is also briefly
mentioned a couple of other times in the
film when lily and frank are discussing
the exploration of the amazon and the
search for the tears of the moon
founded by the aforementioned dr albert
falls the jungle navigation company
limited is a fictional business set
within the adventureland and jungle
cruise world of disney parks
it's a parent company and operator of
the jungle cruise tours of the world's
rivers and also boasts the popular
skipper canteen mess hall style eatery
the company was introduced to disneyland
and magic kingdom's adventureland as
part of updates to the parks in the
1990s
the jungle navigation company's skipper
canteen menu is also full of nods to the
jungle crew's attraction
including dishes named after albert
falls and the attraction's boats there's
also a not piranha sustainable fish dish
which is made all the more funny after
seeing frank serve up fresh piranha in
the jungle cruise movie
in the film a sign burying the jungle
navigation company limited logo can be
seen at the docks as frank tries to get
out of pain nilo
fans of disneyland's enchanted tiki room
were likely thrilled to see a brief but
memorable jungle cruise cameo by rosita
the cockatoo
the white feathered rosita is one of the
showgirl birds who appear in the
attraction and seeing let's all sing
like the birdies sing
however rosita's spot on the mobile is
empty because she left the group for
adventures elsewhere
she now inhabits various spots around
disneyland including the tropical
hideaway and a riverside cage on the
jungle cruise attraction
in the jungle cruise film paul
giamante's character nilo has a pet
cockatoo named rosita who repeatedly
squawks a memorable line frank owes me
money
it's the eighth wonder of the world and
one of the greatest continuous jokes in
theme park bride history
the backside of water jungle cruise riot
fans will laugh at this joke no matter
how many times they've heard it and seen
the other side of the famous schweitzer
falls
boat skippers tell passengers they like
to call it o2h
in the behind the attraction series on
disney plus imagineers behind the jungle
cruise ride and some longtime skippers
said the backside of water joke is an
essential part of the experience
if the joke isn't told guests will
remind the skippers of their misstep
likewise including the backside of water
joke was a must for the jungle cruise
film
it was featured prominently in the first
trailer ladies and gentlemen the moment
you've all been waiting for
the backside of water
that joke and all the others frank's
deadpans elicits groans and eye rolls
from the tourists
in a similar nod to the human-made river
crews at disneyland the character frank
is shown to have rigged many of the
tricks in the water and along the shore
to give his boat to her a more
adventurous feel
to create the backside of water he put
together a system of water troughs
and pulleys to produce a small waterfall
at the best moment to deliver the
one-liner
the jungle cruise ride we know and love
today isn't the same one that buried
passengers along the world's rivers on
disneyland's opening day in 1955.
for almost a decade nature and wildlife
education was the focus of the original
jungle cruise attraction
the corny dad jokes and dry humor didn't
make it into the ride until the 1960s
alongside the backside of water skippers
now make jokes about a group of lions
eating a zebra on the rocks
and sharing the meal with pride there's
also the nile crocodile named ginger who
snaps the skippers call her one tough
cookie johnson's character frank really
leans into the punny skipper role in
jungle cruise when he gestures to some
sandstone rocks frank says
the rocks you see here in the river are
sandstone but
some people just take them for granted
as frank continues his audience's groans
and eye rolls grow in intensity
even prompts a silent wow from one
passenger after saying he got canned
from his previous job at an orange juice
factory because
i couldn't concentrate later in the
movie when frank lily and mcgregor are
being taken to the village of native
headhunters frank says it's not a great
place to
be headed the jungle cruise wouldn't be
the jungle cruise without its
animatronic animals especially the
hippos
in the disneyland ride the boat slowly
moves through the hippo pool while the
skipper tells the passengers to stay
still so as not to rock the boat and
disturb the massive animals
at one point the skipper fires a fake
pistol to scare some of the hippos away
from the boat a brief but similar scene
happens in the jungle cruise movie as
frank narrates the many ways the amazon
jungle has killed previous explorers the
boat rumbles past the stationary fake
hippo protruding from the water
then as frank is activating a bunch of
his tricks to entertain the passengers
he uses
a pistol kept near the boat's wheel to
fire at a rope and unleash the
mechanical roaring hippo
hippos aren't native to the amazon
region a fact pointed out by a young
girl on the boat whom frank shushes so
they aren't seen again in the rest of
the film
at the beginning of 2021 the jungle
cruise ride received some major
storytelling updates to get rid of
negative depictions of native people
which included getting rid of the
unofficial jungle cruise mascot to
trader sam animatronic though trader sam
had different animatronic iterations in
disneyland and
magic kingdom the character was
described by critics as a racist
caricature of indigenous african peoples
trader sam got another revamp in the
jungle cruise movie in the film veronica
falcone portrays trader sam as the
leader of the tribe of indigenous people
who guard the healing treat
she makes several quips about working
with frank and playing outdated
stereotypes of native peoples for his
river crew story and how she makes money
off of colonial notions of her people
the portrayal of trader sam and her
people doesn't always hit the nail on
the head when it comes to reimagining
the character
there is a moment when trader sam dons
lily's brother's top hat and a small nod
to the magic kingdom version of traitor
sam who's not only holding several
shrunken heads but also wearing one as a
necklace
but critics have said the new trader sam
is a quote party attempt to reimagine a
less racist version of the character
this one may be a bit of a stretch but
prince joaquim's submarine is strangely
reminiscent of the nautilus vessel from
disney's 20 000 leaks under the sea
though the interior of the submarine is
cold and cramped joaquin somehow also
has extravagant luxurious quarters that
solidify his bumbling caricature of a
colonizing villain
the famous nautilus submarine was
created by jules verne and featured in
his 1870 novel 20 000 leagues under the
sea
and in the disney film of the same name
from 1954
the nautilus is shaped like a fish and
has a shingled ramming fern at the bow
joaquin's submarine boasts a similar
serrated ramming fern in its battle but
so did many other german ub2 type
submarines during world war one
magic kingdom at disney world had a 20
000 leagues under the sea attraction
that featured a 20-minute submarine ride
aboard an adapted version of nautilus
but the ride was shuttered in 1994
the 1951 adventure classic the african
queen is one of the key elements that
inspired the layout and storytelling of
the original jungle cruise boat ride in
disneyland
70 years later its inspiration lives on
in the jungle cruise film
the film is based on the 1935 novel of
the same name
and stars humphrey bogart as a skipper
fairing a woman played by catherine
hepburn down a river and a boat named
the african queen
the movie is also set during world war 1
and has long been heralded by critics as
thrilling adventurous and
funny with a hint of light-hearted
romance while jungle cruise is obviously
based on the theme park attraction it
clearly also takes inspiration from the
african queen
looper's review of the film said
johnson's frank looks like the human
growth hormone version of bogart with
blunt's character giving her ambitious
scientist a little glint of hepburn
frank also sports a nearly identical
skipper outfit to bogart's charlie
allnut
complete with a red scarf tied around
his neck and a black-filled white cap
the design of frank's creaky hodgepodge
riverboats also pays homage to charlie's
african queen
though jungle cruise is set in 1916 it
does have a nod to disney's true life
adventure nature documentaries which
premiered in the late 1940s ran through
1960 then inspired the original jungle
cruise attraction at disneyland
during a quieter moment in jungle cruise
blonde's character lily uses a box
camera to capture motion pictures of the
wildlife and scenery of the jungle while
sailing down the amazon river
she captures soundless black and white
shots of butterflies birds and foliage
while johnson's frank stares at all
he's never seen a motion picture camera
before so lily lets him try it out
lily also explains the excitement of
motion pictures and how they can bring
any place in the world right to you
it's a similar sentiment shared by walt
disney and his team when shooting and
sharing the true life adventure features
as well as creating the jungle cruise
ride
both the feature and attraction were
made to bring the world to an audience
and give that audience a greater
appreciation for wildlife and nature
yes veteran heavy metal rockers
metallica reworked an orchestral version
of nothing else matters for a key scene
in disney's jungle cruise movie
it's an unexpected but delightful detail
that somehow fits in a flashback scene
set in the mid-1500s with spanish
conquistadors and a tribe of indigenous
people in the amazonian rainforest
metallica drummer lars ulrich talked
about the disney collaboration in
september 2020
saying it goes back to lifelong rock
band sean bailey who is disney's
production president
ulrich worked with the jungle cruise
score composer james newton power to
rearrange nothing else matters into a
piece that's instrumental to the dark
frenzied scene
in an interview with collider ulrich
said the version is a very unusual morph
of the iconic song
the flashback scene is quick and feels a
bit jammed with a lot of plot points
that can be hard to follow but the new
arrangement of nothing else matters is a
dizzying welcome addition to a score
otherwise filled with spirited adventure
ballots
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you